c'est une longue ligne droite la route
qui mène à barmouth peu de véhicules
tous militaires et à l'arrière des
pick-up des couchages et des vivres vous
allez avoir honte
oui mais la ville est quasi encerclée on
voit comment on va y aller
il reste encore 4 km à parcourir et les
nouvelles pour les chauffeurs ne sont
pas bonnes
on peut pas continuer
la route est bombardée j'attends qu'on
me dise où passer
il faut emprunter des chemins de terre
et risqués de s'embourber cette voiture
est parvenue à sortir de Barbeau
la situation est tendue le pont est
cassé là-bas il faut faire des détours
et puis on va bientôt évacuer nos gars
de la ville on va les sortir depuis la
colline on voit les faux bourgs de
barboutes devant nous une énorme colonne
de fumée une explosion
les militaires nous ont donné ces images
du pont détruit sur la route par les
Russes nous croisons des camions qui en
reviennent
on y est pour mettre des graviers
une mission sous les bombes pour tenter
de remblayer de maintenir l'accès à
barmouth la route est constamment
surveillée par les drones de cette unité
hier on en a perdu un
il nous laisse filmer leur écran
c'est quoi ça c'est les tranchées
de venir nous couper la route ici
des positions ennemies à 700 mètres nous
quittons la grande route pour un village
où se joue une bataille décisive
quelques maisons et à notre arrivée
des tirs
combat tout autour du village le
commandement est dans cette cave les
lignes ennemies à un kilomètre
les points là c'est les trous d'obus les
nôtres et les leurs les soldats se
cachent dans les maisons
il nous disent attendre les renforts de
Kiev
il faut tenir ici à tout prix car s'ils
prennent le village ils peuvent
encercler bammouth
et ses chemins debout la ville devenue
symbole ne s'est toujours pas libres ce
que vous ne pas parce que les Ukrainiens
ne veulent pas le montrer c'est qu'ils
sont en train tout autour de ces
villages de sécuriser des routes à
travers champs pour assurer la retraite
de barmouth si elle doit avoir lieu